someone asks chomsky hates big pharma
and big corporations
but wants to insist people patronize
pfizer moderna johnson and johnson and
so on
why trust these companies and the
government in this area given there are
many independent virologists
and vaccine developers who advise
against mass vaccination during a
pandemic such as geert vandenbosch
where's
question number 46 46
46 yep
okay
all right
why these companies
and the government
given that there are some
independent virologists and
of vaccine developers who oppose max
vaccination
well the answer is i'm in favor of
vaccination it's because of the
overwhelming evidence overwhelming
that vaccination
radically
radically reduces infection
and
cuts back radically cuts back
uh this severe disease and contagion
and also reduces the pool for mutation i
think the evidence on that is quite
overwhelming
has nothing to do with your attitudes
towards
big pharma or government
just
simply take a look at the
take a look at the map that appears in
every day
in the new york times
about hot spots this morning for example
uh what is remarkable facts sean
the places that are the worst hot spots
are shown in red
then
less bright colors for others
one thing that's striking
dramatic
about the global hot spots
is that the united states is the prime
offender in the world
stands and there are a few other places
scattered around that are red but the
big
dark red areas are the united states
that is an astonishing fact
this is the richest country in the world
most powerful country in the world
has natural advantages that
no other country has
and it's the worst place in the world
for dealing with the pandemic
if you look more closely at the map of
the united states you see exactly why
the red spots
are essentially the old confederacy
and a few outliers like wyoming and
idaho with
republican
run by republicans
what does that tell you
you look a little closer you see these
are the states where people are refusing
vaccination
then if you go even closer
you look into the hospitals in alabama
idaho what you find is
desperate
totally desperate nurses and doctors
trying somehow to deal
with the flood of cases
almost entirely unvaccinated
overwhelming
first studies are just beginning to come
out came out yesterday
of
the
sharp rise
in covet infections
among children
too young to get vaccinated now these
are preliminary studies so
just
a surmise so far but so far what they
show
is exactly what you could predict
these are the children of unvaccinated
parents
okay
now around around the world you find the
same thing
that's why health officials
everywhere
are calling for more extreme vaccination
now there are a few people who say there
are some of those mentioned who say well
there are possible dangers in
vaccination you know that's true of
vaccination generally it's true of polio
it's true of measles there are possible
dangers
but
now we turn to an interesting
sociological phenomenon
in the past
there have been plenty of vaccinations
and vaccine mandates
so for schools
in the united states i presume other
countries there's a vaccine mandate
for
sending a kid to school
you can't send a kid to school who
hasn't had the polio vaccine
which is correct
that
protects children
from the danger
now yes
there's some danger in polio vaccines
it's always been understood
same kind of dangers that are pointing
out today but nobody ever paid attention
to it before
so we have a strange sociological
phenomenon
right now there are major movements
major movement most of them on the far
right but the left as well
saying we have to pay attention to the
kind of dangers that have always been
known
and we have to pay attention to the few
outliers who say well maybe these
dangers outweigh the benefit of
vaccinations and we should ignore the
fact that literally millions of people
are dying
from lack of vaccination
now that's a sociological problem
why is it different now than ever before
why is there a group of people who
eagerly latch on
to any
straw of evidence that there might be
something wrong with mass vaccination
and there are always such draws why is
that happening
my suspicion is it's another
reflection of a
collapse of the social order
and a serious decline
of the general environment of
rational discourse and
civilized interchange shows up in many
areas and i suspect that this is part of
it
do you think we should force vaccines or
mandate them
i don't think we should force vaccines
but i think we should protect people
from those who decide
i want to be free to endanger others
if people don't want to be vaccinated
fine they should have the decency to
segregate themselves
go somewhere
don't go to it don't go to a concert
where you endanger others
okay if you don't want your kid to have
a polio vaccine
you're not forced to do it
but don't send them to school to
endanger other children
so i'm in favor of vaccine mandates i
think they're crucial for ending
at least trying to contain this
disease which is rampant in the united
states
because of the
strange sociological phenomenon that i
mentioned
the unusual breakdown
of
the social order
and
rational civilized discourse which we
see in many areas
take a look at the polls of republicans
it's astonishing
about a quarter of republicans
think the government is run by
an elite of
sadistic pedophiles
who are carrying out experiments on
young children
i mean
it's total madness you know this is
higher than the percentage of people who
support organized religions that runs
through
i mean a majority of republicans say
they're not going to get vaccinated
well there are also
sectors the left which
have been caught up in this
strange disorder and as i said are
eagerly seeking
any fragment of evidence
however weak that might question the
overwhelming evidence of the efficacy of
vaccines